this video was going around yesterday
this is a couple years ago this is
trudeau talking about the country that
he admires most
even with sun tv watching for any slip
he was asked which country he most
admired and referred to china there's a
level of
admiration i actually have for china
because their
basic dictatorship is allowing them
to actually turn their economy around on
a dime and say we need to go green as
fast as we need to start you know
investing in solar
it's so beautiful it's so beautiful when
they tell you exactly what they are and
that's exactly what he did there i come
in with rainbows and unicorns
intolerance and love and
lgbtqi what are all the other letters
you've all seen the video
but who does he really admire when push
comes to shove he really admires china
and why does he admire china because
china doesn't give a flying f about
their citizens individual rights china
is a collectivist society so you know
what happens in a collectivist society
where everyone basically has to bow to
the government the government can get a
lot done and that's what trudeau is
saying there's a lot of things that i
want to get done and you know what you
got to crush when you're trying to get a
lot done you have to crush the
individual and that's what this all
boils down to the individual versus the
state and trudeau at some level is not
really a person and what i mean by that
i don't mean it to dehumanize him i mean
it in that he just represents something
a government a conglomerate a
corporation a worldwide whatever that's
what trudeau is as a person that's why
he reeks of inauthenticity right that's
why
you know that everything he's saying is
a lie that nothing is is truly
passionate or decent that comes out of
him right because he doesn't represent
himself he represents an idea a bad idea
so you got to crush all the individuals
along the way so what he's saying there
is i do
i dig china because they can get [ __ ]
done so i come in i sound like a nice
guy but really what i am is an awful
authoritarian uh
we can just put that right next to this
video from yesterday about uh compelling
people to do what he wants
in windsor
we relied on
generous partnership with the americans
to be able to get tow trucks to move the
big trucks
now with these
measures that we've put in place
there will be an ability to compel
for just compensation
tow truck owners and operators to
actually do the jobs for which they have
contracts with various orders of
government to keep highways and roads
clear
they're gonna compel them to do that
stuff that's how they're going to compel
them how do you think they're going to
compel them they're going to pay
you know they're going to take other
people's money
that they pay in taxes to compel them to
do things that perhaps they don't want
to do and then you might say to the
people hey if you don't do the stuff
that we're compelling you to do we might
actually shut your bank accounts i mean
this is a bad dude
bad dude
and what's interesting about this is as
i said they always come in with this
rainbow thing they come in with the
diversity thing they're the good guys
and then very quickly and that is the
silver lining here guys right like we're
they're being unmasked right in front of
us right that's why all the progressives
in america right now and all our news
networks are either ignoring this or
obfuscating what's really going on i'll
get more on that in just a second
because it's their people that are now
being shown to be the worst right if
this was if trudeau was saying these
very things and he was a leader say in
the arab world in the middle east and he
was saying hey if you go against me and
protest me we're not gonna let you have
bank accounts um we're gonna compel
people to do certain things right uh
we'd have biden out there going you know
well maybe we should invade there should
be some sort of invasion we should you
know be encouraging but we've been
through this before look what happened
in egypt with hosni mubarak who was the
dictator there for 30 years and then
obama after two days of protest obama
was like yeah we're done with that guy
but look how we operate a little bit
differently when it's justin trudeau up
in canada but one of the things that
they come in with is this diversity all
this faux
you know tolerance stuff but what they
love is the idea of unity right they're
always talking about unity we should be
united
they don't mean it what they mean is
that half the people should just bow
but trudeau because he needs unity he
needs the idea of unity he's now telling
the canadian people that what's
happening right now it's not even
dividing canadians it's all good
um
it has been clear that this is something
that democracies around the world are
concerned with
countries that did well
during the pandemic with high
vaccination rates and strong public
health measures
are still seeing
backlashes against those measures
and
frustration by people who are tired of
this pandemic
and the
impact of
social media and
illicit funding of
concerted activities designed to
destabilize a country that has the
highest vaccination rate of many of our
peer countries canada
around an issue that is not dividing
canadians canadians are united in having
been there for each other through this
pandemic and they're even united in
being sick and tired of this pandemic
but the way to get through it
is not to shut down our economy and hurt
our neighbors
remember i said a week ago or so that
when i did the show here in miami with
jordan peterson about two weeks ago that
there was a question about justin
trudeau that was asked by the audience
and uh jordan said that justin trudeau
is simply incapable of saying a true
statement and you really can feel it
right there because he needs unity right
because he loves they love this idea of
conformity and collectivism and what
that would mean is that there would be
no dissenting voices right because they
know what's good for you so the the lie
there is just incredible as he is
literally passing emergency powers to
stifle dissent in his supposed free
country
as he's doing that telling people that
their bank accounts will be shut down
that they will be arrested if they're
out on the streets and god only knows
what they're doing behind the scenes
he's telling you that they're united
they're united and at the same time
everybody loves what we've done here
everybody loves the masks everybody
loves the mandates they love me look at
my hair they gotta love me i'm justin
trudeau
it's so bananas ridiculous they lie
about everything and then i saw this uh
connor let's pull this up rasmussen
reports had a new study that 59
of us voters support canadian truckers
in the freedom convoy protest the reason
i thought this was interesting is
because this story as i've mentioned is
basically being ignored or lied about on
mainstream media so we've shown you some
clips from cnn don't worry guy we're not
going to do it right now we're not
showing the cnn clips but we've showed
you some clips of cnn and msnbc and a
bunch of other news networks where
they're basically calling all of the
protesters racists and their bigots and
you know they're anti-vaxxers and a
whole bunch of other nonsense and
they're they're calling them violent and
all of the stuff
so the fact that basically 60
of americans on a rasmussen poll i mean
rasmussen is a pretty reputable poll
pollster the fact that 60 percent of
americans are with them
is incredible